♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
IF YOU HAVE BEEN WATCHING
THE OTHER CHANNELS LATELY
THERE IS ONE THING YOU
LEARNED ABOUT THE CARAVAN OF
CENTRAL AMERICAN MIGRANTS
MARCHING TOWARD OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER THE WHOLE THING IS NO
BIG DEAL.
THESE ARE NICE PEOPLE, EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM.
MUCH BETTER PEOPLE THAN YOU
ARE.
THEY HAVE THE DEEP MORAL
AUTHORITY THAT COMES FROM
LIVING IN A THIRD WORLD
COUNTRY UNLIKE YOU,
MR. PAMPERED SUBURBANITE.
THEY ARE NOT INVADERS,
FUTURE SUPER AMERICANS.
NOT NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT.
THAT'S BEEN THE CHORUS FROM
POLITICIANS AND NEWS ANCHORS
WHO THINK THEY ARE
POLITICIANS FOR WEEKS AND
WEEKS NOW.
IF YOU HAVE ANY CONCERN AT
ALL ABOUT THIS CARAVAN, YOU
ARE A BAD PERSON.
IN FACT, YOU, SIR, ARE A
RACIST.
>> ALL OF THIS FOR A GROUP
OF PEOPLE, A LOT OF WHOM ARE
MOTHERS AND CHILDREN WHO
POSE NO IMMINENT THREAT TO
THE UNITED STATES.
>> CALL THIS INVASION.
IT MIGHT BE THE MOST
PATHETIC INVASION OF A
COUNTRY IN WORLD HISTORY IF
THIS WERE ACTUALLY AN
INVASION.
OF COURSE, IT'S NOT.
>> PRESIDENT SENDING TROOPS
TO THE BORDER TO DEAL WITH
THE CARAVAN THAT HASN'T
PROVEN TO BE VIOLENT.
>> STOP SAYING THEY ARE
MONSTERS THERE ARE MORE
MOTHERS THAN MONSTERS.
DON'T SAY IT.
WHY DON'T ANY OF YOU SAY
THAT?
>> Tucker: THERE IS THE LINE
OF THE DAY.
MORE MOTHERS THAN MONSTERS.
TURNS OUT THAT'S NOT QUITE
RIGHT.
MORE BROTHERS THAN MOTHERS,
ACTUALLY.
ACCORDING TO THE BORDER
PATROL, THE CARAVAN IS IN
FACT ABOUT 70% SINGLE MEN.
NOT FAMILIES, WOMEN, AND
CHILDREN.
BUT OVERWHELMINGLY SINGLE
MEN.
ACCORDING TO MEXICO'S OWN
AMBASSADOR, MANY IN THE
GROUP ARE, QUOTE.
VERY VIOLENT.
THAT'S WHAT
VIAT'S WHAT
VIOL'S WHAT
VIOLEN WHAT
VIOLENT.HAT
VIOLENT.STT
VIOLENT.STATE NPR.
HEAVY MALE AND HIGHLY
DANGEROUS.
WHEN THE AMERICAN AMBASSADOR
SAYS THAT TO PUBLIC RADIO
WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT
OBVIOUSLY WITH S. RACISM,
MORE WHITE WINGY.
DISHONESTY FROM THE VERY
PEOPLE PAID CONTINUE TO FORM
US.
THERE IS NOTHING TO WORRY
ABOUT THEY TELL US LIKE WE
ARE CHILDREN.
THEY DON'T REALLY KNOW
ANYTHING.
THEY ARE WHOLLY IGNORANT AND
UTTERLY SELF-CONFIDENT.
THEY ARE GOOD AT MORALIZING
AND LIGHT ON FACTS.
WHO EXACTLY IS IN THE
CARAVAN?
A LOT OF THEM PROBABLY ARE
WHAT THEY APPEAR TO BE, POOR
PEOPLE FROM DISORGANIZED
COUNTRIES LOOKING FOR A
BETTER LIFE.
IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE.
BUT ARE SOME OF THEM GANG
MEMBERS, TOO?
HOW ABOUT DRUG DEALERS OR
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS?
SHUT UP, SAY THE NEWS
ANCHORS.
DON'T ASK THOSE QUESTIONS.
BUT IF YOU REALLY CARED
ABOUT AMERICA, YOU WOULD
WANT ANSWERS TO THOSE
QUESTIONS.
YOU WOULD INSIST ON KNOWING.
WOULD YOU LET YOUR KIDS
SLEEP AT A STRANGER'S HOUSE?
PROBABLY NOT.
YOU LOVE YOUR KIDS.
OUR LEADERS OUGHT TO FEEL
THE SAME WAY ABOUT US.
THEY DON'T.
INSTEAD THEY SEE THEIR OWN
COUNTRYMEN AS THE REAL
THREAT.
IN THE MINDS OF THE PEOPLE
MAKING OUR COUNTRY'S RULES,
FOREIGNERS ARE ALWAYS
SUPERIOR TO AMERICANS.
WATCH DON LEMON EXPLAIN.
>> SO WE HAVE TO STOP
DEMONIZING PEOPLE AND
REALIZE THE BIGGEST TERROR
THREAT IN THIS COUNTRY IS
WHITE MEN, MOST OF THEM
RADICALIZED TO THE RIGHT,
AND WE HAVE TO START DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT THEM.
THERE IS NO TRAVEL BAN ON
THEM.
THERE IS NO BAN ON, YOU
KNOW, THEY HAD THE MUSLIM
BAN.
THERE IS NO WHITE GUY BAN.
SO WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT THAT?
>> Tucker: WE HAVE TO START
DOING SOMETHING ABOUT THEM,
DON LEMON SAYS.
KEEP IN MIND THAT HE IS
TALKING ABOUT AN ENTIRE
RACIAL GROUP CURRENTLY
LIVING IN THIS COUNTRY.
WHAT EXACTLY DOES DON LEMON
HAVE IN MIND FOR, QUOTE,
DEPORTATION?
INTERNMENT CAMPS?
MORE AFFIRMATIVE ACTION?
IT WOULD BE GOOD TO KNOW.
SOME OF US WOULD LIKE TO
TELL OUR SONS WHAT'S COMING.
WE CONTACTED CNN TODAY TO
ASK THEM WHAT THEY QUOTE
PLAN TO START DOING TO THIS
RACIALLY GROUP OF RACIALLY
DEFECTIVE AMERICANS, THEY
NEVER APPLIED.
MAYBE LEMON WILL BE MORE
SPECIFIC ABOUT HIS PLANS ON
TONIGHT'S SHOW.
WITHOUT EVEN HEARING THE
DETAILS, IT'S PRETTY CLEAR
WHERE THE PEOPLE ON TV
STAND.
THEY INSTINCTIVELY SIDE WITH
FOREIGN NATIONALS OVER
AMERICAN CITIZENS IS EVERY
TIME.
IF YOU ARE WONDERING WHY
THEY ARE FAR MORE UPSET
ABOUT MIGRANT CAMPS IN
MEXICO THAN HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS IN ORANGE
COUNTY.
THAT'S WHY.
YESTERDAY IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" A COLUMNIST TOLD
MICHELLE GOLDBERG NOTED IF
THE ELECTIONS IN GEORGIA IF
THE BAD OLD PEOPLE DON'T
AGREE WITH HER AGENDA ARE
DISPLACED BY A LARGE GROUP
OF NEW PEOPLE WHO DO.
HER PIECE IS TITLED WE CAN
REPLACE THEM.
IMAGINE WRITING SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT ABOUT YOUR FELLOW
AMERICANS.
IMAGINE RUNNING IT IN YOUR